I mean this dish has it all it's got
sweet it's got salty it's got a mommy
hi I'm Santos I'm a food stylist and
today I'm making shout father mariscos
my grandfather emigrated from Canton to
Peru he opened up a chief our restaurant
this menu that I have here is actually
an original menu from his restaurant so
starting with the mussels you want to
pull the beard off so just give it a
nice tug and take it off and then just
rinse the shells
I grew up along the coast of Peru small
town called Branca where my grandfather
had a cheaper restaurant so everyone in
the family at some point cooked in that
restaurant what I like about this dish
is that it's a good example of what
chief uh cuisine is about you add in the
oil and then just when it begins to
smoke add in the whisked eggs and then
season it with salt this is really
important so chief of cuisine is the
fusion of Chinese and Peruvian
ingredients this dish represents my
heritage
I'm Peruvian Chinese and then the
tossing together of these ingredients in
the wok it's like blending together the
two cultures so in this case we're gonna
use a Hiyama do we're gonna use pisco ah
here Mario is a Peruvian chili pepper
you take the pepper you chop it you add
garlic into it and then using a Stone
grinder you make a paste and so from
there you can cook with it or from there
you can use it as a condiment when
cooked it offers a fruity flavor a mild
heat but most important it provides
color to the dish
right now we're watching Chifa happening
this is chief R right here guys
this is Peru meets China pay attention
it's really important as you're building
the layers to add salt and taste you
want to season throughout to make sure
that every step of the way is being
seasoned correctly just be careful
because we're in soy sauce we're adding
oyster sauce those two things naturally
have salt but just make sure you taste
along the way it's important to wipe the
walk down at this point so that your
sausage doesn't stick to the wok because
we added in oyster sauce which has a lot
of sugar and so it sticks to the wall
in this dish is Chinese five-spice so
the spices in that our cinnamon cloves
fennel star anise and Sichuan peppercorn
it's got an umami it's smoky it's a
little sweet from the star anise most
often this dish is served in a large
platter so when you're gathering with
your friends or your family this is part
of the banquet along with other dishes
and and it's meant to be shared when I
moved to Brooklyn from Peru I wanted to
be American so badly that I was willing
to just forget where I had come from my
parents don't know this I changed my
name to Mike but I was only Mike on
Fridays as I got older I realized that
the thing that I had left behind was the
one thing that would actually make me
unique in life you know for anybody
experiencing the same thing that I had I
would say you don't need to sacrifice
where you come from to be something else
I think that you can find a balance and
be both things people just got to love
you for who you are and different is
always better oh yes
[Music]
you